we now know the identity of a man killed
in the northwest valley yesterday the
las vegas review journal confirming it
was one of their own jeff german was
found dead with stab wounds outside his
home around 10 30 yesterday morning mary
jane belliesa joins us in the newsroom
tonight with more on how his colleagues
are remembering him mary jane
well it's a huge loss for the journalism
and las vegas community those who knew
him say jeff german's work made an
impact across the valley as an
established journalist investigative
reporter jeff gearman was found dead
with stab wounds outside his home
saturday morning he was 69 years old and
has covered news in the valley for
decades working at the las vegas sun and
las vegas review journal her own ron
food trail describes the death as
shocking they both worked closely
together investigating the removal of
jerry tarkanian as unlv's basketball
coach
i came in this morning and
was surprised shocked saddened
certainly that this had happened
to jeff you know knowing him very well
and knowing what he's been in this
community what he's done in this
community
and to think that some sort of needless
tragedy like this could happen
futrell adds german's tenacity and
research to uncover a story really set
him apart and made him fearless now
metro police say they believe a fight
led to german stabbing and police are
still searching for the suspect but do
say they do have a lead live in the
newsroom mary jean bellezza 8 news now
in a statement from the review journal
executive editor and senior vice
president glenn cook says quote jeff
german was as competitive relentless
trusted and accomplished as any reporter
in nevada for the past four decades he
broke big stories and developed
impactful investigations across every
part of southern nevada life from
politics to sports local and state
government to courts and business to
organize crime he will be terribly
missed by his family and colleagues and
we are all in shock over his senseless
killing his loss is unfathomable and he
is irreplaceable